what's happening reject nation Greg Alba
here Wahlberg okay Rasputin yelling well
Mark Wahlberg and Peter Berg are
reuniting again and our buddies they do
some pretty good movies together I think
I haven't seen all but the big hype
about this mile 22 movies
ecoute who why Asst I'd never learn to
say his name but he's a person I love
watching we love the first to raid films
a hell of a ton he's in this film and we
want to give a patient of the day shot
tuna Raj Krishnan we got a lot of
requests for this but nur Raj Krishnan
over at patreon sent us a link and he
was the first one to tell us about this
he is a patron who is constantly sending
us trailer requests he's very
interactive with us he's a huge
cinephile is all the way in the East
Coast but he's a good friend of the
channel really love this guy a hell of a
lot Niraj thank you for supporting us
for such a long time buddy one day we
will meet you in person and I will make
you some scrambled eggs one of the few
things I know how to make and I'll
microwave you some oscar meyer bacon
look out it's a feast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
looking on the plane to the US
[Music]
[Music]
I can't cheat
and this is a Peter Berg movie for sure
[Music]
[Music]
well I'm Mark Wahlberg just seems cool
throughout this whole situation yeah one
that mean he's the only character
practically except for ego wise and John
Malkovich who gets to talk it all got a
bunch of other people this movie are all
the background of this dude I mean every
scene that you see Mark Wahlberg in
throughout this whole intense time
crunch situation he's always really cool
after doing like lone survivor Patriots
a Deepwater Horizon Peter Berg's likes
to a movie where you just kind of like
just cool or none of those emotional
stakes [ __ ] anymore you just can't play
whatever be cool why excuse me I've
never properly learned to say this guy's
name I'm excited that he's in this movie
actually looks like he has something to
do yeah I'm like that force awakens
thingamajiggy he gets the chance to
actually you know show off his fighting
skills and when this trailer was first
happening and it's they're really
singing him up like he's a bad guy at
first and the owner maybe he just
becomes a package they asked to deliver
he's working with them so he's not like
the bad dude in the film because I
annoys me I'm like of course you bring
over to hug from another country's a
badass martial artist he's making the
bag there's other cast members here who
kind of just look like they're filling
the typecast roles you know John
Malkovich as head of whatever agency
they are like cool Loren climbs in this
movie doesn't longer doing much you know
Ronda Rousey is also Peter Berg he hops
between like these intense traumatic
films to action movies you know when I
was introduced to Peter Berg's directing
it was movies like The Rundown
lone survivor this reminded me more of
the kingdom which has a ticking time
clock too it is a very specific type of
crunch time imagine is probably gonna be
some insane intense finale with this
film but I was watching this this looked
like yeah looks like action generic
Peter Berg film me yeah yeah I mean with
some bone crunching action that scene in
the hospital is probably what sold me
the most on this and it made me wonder
too I mean if he brought his
choreography team with him
or whatever you kohu why yeah cuz like
you know I mean I'm interested to see
how Peter burgers gonna capture fighting
like that cuz I know how you can capture
gunplay I'm sure it's gonna be really
handheld gritty yeah yeah yeah yeah are
we gonna get some of those oh [ __ ]
moments that were you to from you know
that style of martial arts or is it
gonna be kind of buried in you know this
kind of shaky you get a hints of it like
it was the fight scenes here that looked
way more appealing than the gunplay like
the gunplay looked a little generic to
me looks intense cuz the situation
there's so many people cocking guns
through yeah shots have like them firing
assault rifles but like a hospital scene
any teen with eco wise does the push
with his kick yeah she's the guy that
was a cool moment yeah I mean this is
one of those movies you're gonna go in
just for the action I think Mark
Wahlberg and both Peter burger aware of
that yeah thrilling and cool as possible
especially after the last couple of
films they did together it looks like
these taking more of a chill experience
with this yeah quite so gravitas but it
looks cool looks fun
I mean I'll check it out this looks also
like an STX film alright guys well you
can subscribe well guys thanks for
recommending this to us do you think
this is gonna be a great American film
for equalise to be in I know when this
channel first started growing and had a
lot to do with us covering the raid but
any Indonesian subscribers are still
here let us know guys you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell to get notified
when one of our videos is up because
subscribe button suck and you can check
us out on patreon a full-length TV show
reactions music video coverage weekly
Q&A is plenty of goodies over there I'd
love to have you become a pot product
good die